oculus rift is a next-generation virtual
reality headset and of course someone
most likely a Japanese guy pretty sure
it is connected it with sex machine
[Music]
[Music]
there's a lot there okay so the device
that the robot is holding is called a
Tenga which is a Japanese masturbation
device and obviously if he was in the
privacy of his own home his penis would
be in that thing and there wouldn't be a
bunch of people gawking at him I assume
there's a lot of interesting things
about this because as part of this it
goes to like Japanese images of
sexuality because they have a cartoon
which almost looks like a child but
there they have a lot of like you know
the anime stuff and and all that so
they've let's we can get rid of that
part for now robot sex it's coming will
you partake well I mean if a robot could
do kind of Lingus properly that might be
interesting robot sex it's coming you
know here's the thing you can argue
either way you could say look this is
gonna make people strive for less
intimacy this is gonna make men less
likely to watch you impress a woman and
have a girlfriend if they could sit home
and stick their dick in some weird
Japanese anime jerk-off machine you're
fine but this is where it's headed
because we are people and people like
sex and whether we like it or not that's
one of our huge drives is to innovate
stuff for sexuality so people are
surprised or want to stop it good luck
because there's no stopping this once
this start and and not if this is not
for everybody clearly you know I mean
not everyone buys the blowup doll and
goes home and screws that there's most
women own or have owned at some point a
vibrator or something like that and that
does not make them not engage in
relationships with man and that could be
first seen as the first type of robot
sex this is a battery power different
thing used to plug them in or something
this is an energy powered non human
something that most women have
interacted with at some point in their
life that people will say oh it doesn't
that make them wanna be less intimate
and no that didn't make that happen is
there a difference between men and women
with this going back to our last story
about women appointment because I think
for women being able to please ourselves
in that way has been a very empowering
for women sexually and it was part of
the sexual revolution and women have
been doing it for thousands of years and
I think men were a little jealous of
that actually
you know we could you know replace them
in some way but like you said it's not a
replacement I mean if it becomes a
replacement I think you have a bit of a
pathology and you need to go see
somebody but it will I mean there's
going to be an X amount of people that
it absolutely will for sure and this is
part of that you know I mean there's
always an X amount of people who are on
the pathological side of everything you
know eating Oreos there's a pathological
version of that so in eating Oreo sex
robot at the same time and that's in
America you know I remember when I was
like 12 or something I was in Toronto
and I some like future exhibit or
something and they had virtual reality
and I put like a thing on and I walked
in this like virtual world and I thought
this was the most amazing thing ever and
I thought it was going to be like three
years later like we were all gonna be
doing this but virtual reality really
hasn't quite caught on but so is it
gonna take sex because you know the porn
industry does do everything it took film
to VHS right and then it took VHS to DVD
so it is gonna be sex that drives more
about sex than we do walking in a
virtual reality of trees or being at the
Grand Canyon
you know the simulated Eiffel Tower is
nowhere near as cool as a simulated
[ __ ] because we are so still an
animal species and sex is really
important for the species I mean it is
our number one drive is to keep the
species going and we found a lot of
interesting ways to play around those
edges but that's the bottom line sex
does drive everything after all Freud
was right dammit thinking like right now
you come home and like your boyfriend is
in the middle of masturbating maybe he
just like shuts the laptop or throws his
phone away it just kind of covers it up
if your mom walks in on you you're like
I'm [ __ ] and cover it with a pillow what
do you do now with this contraption you
can't like you know be like honey I'm
home the Japanese screen jerking them
all exactly this is like exactly this
makes it a lot more it's a lot more
complicated just to simply get off when
you own the technology you could have
built-in warning systems cameras
infrared drip alarms all
things to protect you in your little sex
dome like there's wow it really it's
just a big WOW for me like we dropped
the microphone at a machine that feed
you and [ __ ] you that's pretty nice
problem
[Music]